first new property on the strip in a
decade opens here in just two days
resorts world alex it greets guests on
thursday one of us i know will be there
in particular actually two of us because
bianca's one of them
should be live she is live now from las
vegas boulevard right by resorts world
with a look at the long history of that
north strip property hi bianca
hey good morning john good morning alex
so time is ticking down
construction crews are still out here
working down to the wire putting the
final touches and we're here
at the main entrance where you would
drive into the hotel entrance of here at
the conrad
tower here and so there's a mega
property
planned for this property on thursday
and well once it opens this will be the
place to check
out this summer it cost 4.3 billion
dollars to build but
it has all the bells and whistles you
can think of from casino to clubs five
acre pool complex 3500 rooms and suites
and construction for all this started
back in may of 2015.
recently we've seen landscaping go up
giant screens
as well go up and be posted up and so
resorts world promises to redefine many
things including gaming
resorts world will be the first in town
to offer cashless gaming
slots at tables and of course the slots
resource world president
scott sabella says that this is just
what las vegas needs
coming out of the pandemic it's exciting
to see that las vegas is starting to
rebound
this city is resilient we've proven that
in the past that it will bounce back
faster
and we're excited that we're happy we're
going to help the city rebound faster
and of course for the foodies they have
something for everybody
they've got 40 food and beverage options
and the property is also adding
entertainment leader to their title as
well with a concert venue large enough
for 5 000 people and also you may be
wondering about all the construction
happening in front well some of that
road construction and las vegas
improvement project that's going to be
adjusted for thursday as they welcome
guests here for the grand opening it's
going to be huge so
those traffic issues are going to be
just slightly
different on thursday and of course
hector will be talking more about that
when thursday comes so that you can plan
in advance reporting live from resorts
world bianca holman 8 news now
you know bianca and alex i remember for
so long that property was just the
parking garage
for a long time that project was stalled
to defeat see it actually come to
fruition is so remarkable
yeah with the biggest monitor you'll
ever see you can't miss it thanks
all right thanks bianca we'll have much
more coverage of this all week long
and hey if those 40 food options she's
talking about aren't enough for you
if you stay at resorts world you can
also get grubhub delivered
right to your room the two companies
have teamed up for a first of its kind
partnership
so you can order food drinks even retail
items from the property
have it delivered right to you up to
your room even at the pool
you can also charge the order to your
room bill that is
way too convenient and dangerous
dangerous but
wonderful